Technology has brought us to a point where we can no longer believe...
...everything we hear, read or even see.
This altered video of U.S. House Speaker Nancy Pelosi...
...was slowed down to make her sound intoxicated.
In 2018, misinformation was to blame...
...for fueling chaos, confusion, violence and death in Myanmar.
It triggered mob attacks that left dozens dead in India.
Experts are calling this current era "information disorder."
Its main contributors are misinformation,...
...which is when false information is shared without the intention to harm...
...and disinformation, when false information is knowingly shared to cause harm.
And while research has shown that YouTube played a major part...
...in convincing some people that the Earth is flat,...
...technology isn't the only factor to blame in all of this.
There is also a growing distrust for science and institution.
Social media giants like Facebook, Twitter and Google...
...have promised to curb misinformation on topics like vaccines...
...so legitimate news sources are prioritized instead of posts with higher engagement.
And then there are companies like Storyful.
The agency finds, verifies and licenses user-generated, newsworthy or viral content...
...on behalf of media organizations including global news.